انا كتبت الكتاب قبل اكثر من عشره اعوام
وانا ذاك كانت الادب الذي يتحدث من داخل
بيت الحركه الاسلاميه كان صحيحا وكان
محدودا
ولاسيما ان الحركه التي تحدثت عنها كانت
حاكمه لمده عشر سنوات
وكان كثير من قراراتها
وما يظهر منها
يشوبه الغموض بالنسبه لحتى المثقف
والسياسي في السودان وفي خارجه الكتاب كان
محاوله
للتجوال داخل
ذهن السلطه وداخل مطبخها وكيف تحدث
التقلبات داخل
ذهن السلطه وكيف تنتقل
وهذا التطور والتحول الذي رصته
كان بمثابه مؤشر قوي لكثير من الناس ان
هذه الحركه قد وصلت الى طريق مسدود وان
كنت عندما كتبت الكتاب لما كنا اعتقد هذا
الاعتقاد ولكن بعد ان كتبت الكتاب وفي
المسار المراجعات المستمر وبتامل الحركات
الاسلاميه في العالم كله وليس السودان فقط
انتهيت الى نتيجه ان الاسلام السياسي قد
استنفذ اغراضه
بمعنى ان الرؤيا والفكره والاطروحه قد
جربت في مستويات مختلفه بما فيها مستوى
الدوله واثبت انها غير قادره على الاجابه
على اسئله العصر ولذلك لا بد من نقله
جديده وانا دعوت الى القطيعه النفسيه
والمعرفيه مع ماضي الحركات الاسلاميه التي
بدات في القرن قبل الماضي مع الافغاني
والرضا ومحمد عبده والبنا
فهذه التجربه التي مضى عليها اكثر من قرن
لابد ان يقطع معها وان يتجاوز الى الافق
الانساني الذي يتجلى الان في رؤيه
الديمقراطيه وبحل الاشكال السياسي عبر
الديمقراطيه وتداول السينما للسلطه
هل صحيح الكتاب منع من التداول سيد محبوب
في السودان
لاول مره طبعا كان ممنوع من التداول صدر
قرار من المجلس القومي للصحافه المطبوعات
التي كانت تهيمن عليه السلطه انذاك سلطه
الانقاذ كما كانت تهيمن على كل المؤسسات
فالكتاب كان بمثابه صدمه كبيره له وهم
سارعوا الى قراءته قبل ان يقراه راي العام
السوداني فمنع رسميا وحاول الناشر
زار هذا المكتب مكتب الذي يمنح تراخيص
دخول الكتب زاره اكثر من عشرين مره وكان
يعد في كل مره بان يصدر قراري لان صدر
القرار بمنعه واعترف الامين العام لذلك
المجلس بان الكتاب قد منع وكان اغلب
السودانيين يهربونه من القاهره شاعت نكته
انذاك ان هنالك شيئان ممنوعان في السودان
هما جهاز كشف الذهب وكتاب المحبوب ولكن
كلاهما يدخل من مطار الخرطوم